hello there and welcome to this rather
grim episode of the slow mo guys it's
puke it's your fault you suggested it
down how do you feel that milk not very
strongly to be honest I don't really
like it I mean I have to drink two guns
worth what I have to I don't think
you'll get through one before you need
to Sunday yeah I think so but I think we
should do this you should try and stay
upright as you vote and I'll get it like
so it just sort of dribbles or yeah I
really don't know how to film this at
all we'll just see what I forget you've
ever seen me beautiful I've seen you
people for you was it like yeah alright
I watched you drink maybe five or six
pints and you were fine I never smoked a
cigarette and vomited I just do that so
much bear
how's it so far fine so far I've only
got that about
fitted with calendar mla's oh god I
already feel ill how much power Shekhar
Oh Jeff drinks I think you won't get
through that one before birthday I'll
pop this one here though just so you're
ready
and trying to get a give a thumbs up
when you know if you put it he's done
the best one see now over half way
through the first gallon
[Laughter]
ha
watch it though do another one
make it quick do you record that
Oh God say that happened to lock but
smell it's womenõs like vomit you know
keeps oh it's a horrible smell
you ready yeah it is in slow motion it
just looks like it's coming out of my
mouth like I'm holding all that in my
mouth ilight of it the Sun isn't on you
but it's on the vomit so it's like it's
lit up
[Music]
I just keep that like all the milk all
the milk
[Music]
we
Bloody Disgusting kind of a surf I'd be
filming that
but Thank You internet for suggesting it
over and over again until we finally
cave did it I hate you that Haiti I'm so
full of milk right now you got like the
milk sweats good
yeah I do yeah I think my splits gonna
be white in a couple of hours
wild City Royals should be sure to
follow us on Twitter buy a shirt from
the store is three not one with vomit on
it this one you probably don't want this
bomb on it and thanks for watching we'll
see you on the next video see you next
time
[Music]
yeah